Youfone Out spoken on Ebola
you don't 50 Million dollars
To The Fight Against the baller and Mr
about the chances of containing in
control
with diagnosed in Dallas when you think
now
that is 22 Million People Now Street
countries Are we need to get this Under
Control because not Only A People Dying
of a bolle There uh The Health system so
shut Down so All The Other diseases
measols malaria There is so even More
That's taking Place There at the same
time is We Get A shut Down
spread The Other countries that Richard
country is if you have a good primer hot
course system You should be with the
Handle that so The fact that this
patient was identify the contacts of
intraste I will Confident to cdcs very
much On Top a that I wish Every Come
country Had A he alth  system like that
There aparts of could The Dawn to work
up in building up the compasy that If A few
people have to the Seas There bevil The
Can't